when you're trying to promote something
that costs very little money especially
consumer products it's very difficult to
acquire customers with paid advertising
profitably if you don't have tons of
cash and you're not funded then the two
most profitable strategies for acquiring
customers you get Word of Mouth which is
referrals it's not just having a very
good product which is important but
reminding and encouraging people to
share it the second way is through
Affiliates which means other businesses
or groups that have your desired
audience the difference between a
referral is one customer tells another
customer an affiliate is somebody who
has a bucket of people who are just like
your ideal customer the big thing is
that if you don't have a lot of LTV on
your customers and you just require a
lot of them then you have to go with the
more viral more grassroot ways make it
good enough that it benefits the
customer A and B that the Affiliates
actual thing becomes more valuable with
the addition of your thing too
oh